how's it going Sal good man how are ya
yeah I'm good so I want to send the
sufferer people a little bit that yes
you came to LA to work on your album yes
staying into the Airbnb and then you get
basically stuck there you got a
quarantine there so how long have you
been there now like you're still coming
yeah we've been here since as I say we
came back from Australia at the end of
January and now we're here until the
foreseeable future so we've been here
three months right now and Counting
write your name at least is sunshine in
true do you like the air BB do you like
the rental home is it oh yeah might as I
say it's nice to be honest it's kind of
weird we're all like wandering boys we
never get to stay anywhere for more than
like a week usually or days at a time so
it's kind of nice to be somewhere for a
couple months and we can have like
dinners and watch movies and stuff it's
kind of cool yeah that's true yeah
that's a good philosophy I could
approach to it now yeah I mean everyone
is doing this without their family you
know on the most part yeah your family
is on the other side of the ocean
basically yeah it's how winters have had
this experience not only not with their
family but not in your home that's what
I mean as I say it's so bizarre to just
kind of like the weird thing has not
been away from some used to been away
from them it's just like if anything
goes wrong you can't get there knowing
that's what's hard it's like if if
anything happens to anyone you just saw
the other side of the planet so that's
really hard and everything's like yeah I
mean yeah I know that's thing you're a
very positive person but do you have
those moments where you're just kind of
depressing as I say to be honest I do
like I really do so far with like
anxiety and depression I have done all
my my entire life but I think that's
what kind of are going to the music for
and right now more than ever I feel so
connected to to my fan base and my
family because when we were supposed to
go to South America
and I remember we were like the show got
canceled three shows in four shows in
South America got canceled and outside
my opportunity to connect with my fan
base is not gonna be taken away man
I'm not gonna let that happen so we just
been doing so much that was I don't
wanna do a thing called the young would
shun it's like a punk rock late-night
show it's a little bit nor in cheeky and
we did that and what start as an idea in
my bedroom because it's before the
lockdown happen my fan base just blew it
up and 72 hours later I'm in a TV studio
with five cameras blokes who knows Matt
soon it's going twice going on like
three celebrity guests that can't talk
to each other and I was just saying all
right this is how it's gonna go we're
gonna have some fun John is quarantine
you know I know I think I'm gonna be out
of a job soon if you keep the stuff how
do you like hosting it talk so I made
it's all right to be honest he's kind of
energetic and fun in it ya know it is
and yeah Kelly Osbourne on yeah okay and
Bella Thorne without those people her
Minds been curl are these all people
that you knew before you just get in
touch with them kind of yeah but all my
mates I kind of like everyone spirit
that alternative been a bit naughty so
you don't know what they're about to say
you know I mean I kind of like been on
edge about to face somewhat
controversial and so I mean I kind of
like that my heartbeat in with it and
well yeah man I knew some people some
people I didn't somebody might a Sexton
and everyone saw how kind of crazy it
went at the start and then do it down
yeah and it soon as the album done the
album's finished okay no matter TC mo
and how would you describe the album it
came from the song just came out weird
was the catalyst but what was weird
about weird was that I wasn't going to
point out first you know I mean us
because and it wasn't it didn't but it
was so interesting that I wrote it first
so technically the universe or a sign he
may as well put it out to set the scene
of what the album's gonna be and the
album is like a big coming of age record
I want it to be like a series of skins
okay in album you know I mean it's an
album about life it's a uncensored meat
we
skee album about life you know I mean
off the wall
love it or you'll hate it album about
life and going through that and kind of
been optimistic it talks about sexual
liberation liberation in terms of
identity drugs
love heartbreak in mental health like
it's it's an album about kind of just
coming of age not necessarily growing up
because okay you can come of age it 94
yikes Oh me it's I'm coming baby
yeah yeah you can look in comma major a
time any all stem from me being in the
weirdest time in my life ever imaginable
well back there but back in December
when I wrote weird and it just kind of
spiraled out of control from that what's
the thing that's crazy but weird like
when I heard it I thought oh he just
wrote this you know being in quarantine
like I can't believe you didn't write
this song about to come out now because
I wrote this yeah Wow the ground
underneath my feet feeling like it was
going to through sue I was gonna fall in
tonight B abyss and I said that's what
exactly what it feels that right now so
it really needs to come out right now
and I think like don't wreck your brain
it's gonna be alright we're in a weird
time of life feels pretty apt yes no
absolutely you know I mean and what was
not like shooting a music video in
quarantine and a little bit stressful
but fun well I think because I was like
pointing gesture like it needs to be
good because we were filming on an
iPhone and then I was like mind blown by
how good the iPhone
and we only spent under quid on it we
only spent hundred dollars on it it was
I bought an iPhone mount and a Jesus
statue now no one's ever gonna give me a
budget for this video get it you can do
it from everyone around me my teams are
a little I am we're gonna we're gonna
cut all your budgets from now on I'm
like oh now yeah so how do you feel
about releasing the album right now
because we're kind of artists going both
ways like the weekends still release
this album the baby still released his
been like Lady Gaga and Dixie Chicks
decided to delay there's like how are
you feeling but releasing music and
that's fine I'm just gonna keep dropping
songs because I think I every time I
release music I always want it to be
about current times on a way I'm feeling
songs always like sit here and then the
kind of one day they'll be like all
right it's time for the world to hear me
now you know I mean and then you kind of
go okay sick and the album's gonna come
out at end of this year I think I think
that's still the plan and but obviously
we're taking every day as it comes you
know I mean just to see what happens and
we're almost we're always very
reflective my team like something
happens then we react very reactive you
know I mean some happens and we react to
it and cuz I just loved the way that's
how I am as a person if something
happens I go okay cool
this is happen within a live show okay
I'm trapped I wrote cut my comic book
Jamie know there's another comic book
coming out there's like a million ideas
that going on at once it's always
bouncing back and forth it's kind of
supported by this massive community of
people underneath cause I want to be a
conversation instead of I am releasing
this now I am a little excited of
la-la-land I'm like no no
you